Ole Miss three first-round picks did Ole
Miss football have a good night last
night Pat uh certainly not as good as it
had been anticipated before some wild
events took place I mean yeah they'll
brag about having three first-round
picks which in old missus is remarkable
but the collateral damage from it is is
potentially very severe with you know
the tonsil stuff even the gas mask thing
is the least of their concerns it's the
text messages and lemme tonsils press
conference that came out later on that
that could be I think really problematic
for all this okay what would the fallout
be and was this a true admission of
getting money from a coach well I I've
spoken today with some people that are
you know pretty familiar with NC
double-a cases how they go and they say
this is very powerful incredible
evidence but it's not a slam dunk that
the NC Double I can walk in and say
we've got you red-handed uh because of
some ambiguity what exactly was Laremy
Tunsil answering to uh uh you know did
he understand the questions was you know
is there really clear lines of
communication there with Laremy Tunsil
communicate would he sit down for
interview with the NCAA i would say
probably not now that is eligibility is
over so there's still some some stuff
out there but you know the clear
implication at least from the text
messages is a Laremy Tunsil wanted money
to pay for rent and money to pay for his
mom's electric bill and he went to the
ole miss coaching staff to get is that
somehow admirable Pat that he wanted to
get money to pay for his mom's
electrical bill but well yes except a
305 dollar electric bill where is she
living is she in the fountainbleau and
they stuck her with the whole life the
place I don't know oh man you can't
script sports like that how old was that
last night it was astounding I have
literally never seen live television
like that and I mean when tap
Tunsil is vicious holy cow you don't
want to be on the wrong side of that
person whoever it is because I mean that
was that's going after somebody as hard
as you can at their moment of their
probably their happiest moment as an
athlete so uh and just to see it happen
and then for him for him to maybe admit
it seemingly admit it was crazy for Hugh
Freeze to stand there do an interview
was crazy at the whole thing it was just
like I cannot believe what we're
watching it's that I mean the draft
always has some twists and turns it's
never had a twister like that when does
the n-c-double-a play said phone called
Ole Miss uh I would be shocked if
they're not in oxford by new to me
forget the phone call i would think
they'd be there in first I mean they may
call ahead and say oh pick us up at the
airport or else we'll just show up in
your compliance office one of the two
you know but yeah I mean I think they
got to be there like ASAP I know that
you cover college football you travel a
lot you go to these games give me the
name in the second round that will hear
that you think somebody's going to get a
great pick yeah boy I mean I think
they're there will be several I mean I
think Myles jack is a great great player
and I know there's you know some may be
some reconstruction issues with that
knee but the fact that each still around
in the second round you know
unbelievable athlete this guy was a
great linebacker and a great running
back can cover can tackle can do
everything you want him to do so it
provided he can he can play and I think
I you know eventually should be able to
these knee injuries seem to be
surmountable I think he'll be a steal
the best quarterback who still left is
who you know I I'm not sure about Connor
cook from Michigan I he's got a lot of
skills and a lot of ability and he's
proven himself but there were there were
some definite nagging questions about
him as a leader and work ethic and that
sort of thing so if you I I think say he
will get taken here in the second round
I'm just I'm not on a percent sold that
he will be a great NFL player but easy
he can grow up a lot of guys you see do
grow up when i get the pros thank you
pat and have a great weekend I damn
thank you that's bad for tea from Yahoo
Sports the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience